hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the World Chess
Championship candidates matches of 2007
it's a tournament I am planning to cover
at some point in its entirety so I'm
only going to show you one game uh for
the moment uh but also I would like to
take this opportunity toite to invite
everyone to our Christmas tournament
sponsored by Multiverse X formerly known
as elron I'm expecting a lot of people
to join probably uh if I had to guess
I'd say around 10,000 players will join
at least and you guys will have a chance
as usual when we have a big event to
face some of the uh Stronger players uh
and uh well maybe even compete for the
top prizes yourself so the link is First
Link in the description below uh join
and uh tomorrow not tomorrow today I
will be streaming it and uh starting
some two and a half hours uh should be
should be a lot of fun but now getting
back to this game uh it is Magnus
Carlson who back at back at the time in
2007 was rated some 2710 and leevon was
rated 2750 and this is the first game of
their candidates match uh candidates
qualification match because in those
days you didn't really have a fay
candidates tournament that would qualify
you for a Fed candidates match uh rather
you had well there was a big division in
the Chess World and Vladimir kramnik
held the title of world champion and
they tried to unify it in 2005 2006 uh
but kramnik refused to play uh in sort
of a one tournament that would decide
the world champion but this year he
decided that yes let's play he said that
he would very much prefer to have a
match for the world CH Championship but
he decided to play either way and this
is a tournament organized to decide one
of the uh well not one of the four um uh
candidates for the world candidates
tournament that would also be a world
candidates you know tournaments match
and uh the world champion will be
decided via a tournament so uh quite a
quite a nice idea uh but if you think
about it that's actually how the first
world ch Champion not first world
champion first Fay world champion when
they first started organizing it
seriously through a organization or
rather fiday you know before you had
like tinit had to lasar had to organize
his own match with shinid then
capablanca had to uh you know work his
way through hell for basically six
months of back and forth letters with
Lasker to organize a match with Lasker
uh then you had the same thing when
capablanca took took the title away from
lasar then Alin had to do the same thing
and and then finally there was the big
uh the first candidate tournament where
uh Mikel binik won and that was
basically the start of uh not how we
have it today but basically it was the
start of uh something that would lead to
what we have today uh but yeah in 2007
it was a different story H it was you
know a tournament that was supposed to
unify everything back into what we have
now and this is sort of the result what
we have today uh but like I said I will
cover it in its entirety at some point
let's just check out the game and enjoy
it and if you want to you know uh enjoy
this moment in time with us share a bit
of History first link in the description
below join the tournament and let's play
some chess uh but now let's check out
the game Magnus with the white pieces
opens with Pawn to E4 and leavon uh with
the black pieces replies Pawn to E5
sorry about that uh let me just fix that
we have Knight to F3 by Magnus uh Knight
to C6 and Magnus goes for the RO Lopez
Bishop to B5 we have Pawn to A6 morphy's
the defense Bishop to A4 and Knight to
F6 we have castles and Bishop to E7 so
fairly standard stuff nothing new here
uh D3 we have B5 chasing with the bishop
Bishop B3 and pawn to D6 we have A4 uh
striking against this advancement of
Pawns on the queen side and now Rook to
B8 Magnus trades once captures captures
and now Knight to C3 uh we have Castles
by leavon H3 stopping Bishop to G4 and
now while you would expect something
like B4 leavon goes for Knight to B 4
instead and of course it's a general
idea with black and the Lopez to move
the knight from C6 to enable this Pawn
to be Advanced all the way to C5 and now
there are a couple of moves that were
played in this position even back in
2007 but it is now as of move U 12
Knights to E2 by Magnus that we have a
completely new game so let's see what
happens here leevon advances the pawn to
C5 we have Knight to G3 trying to get
the Knight over to the F5 Square you
know that's a great Square for the
Knight Bishop to E6 and now Magnus
trades with Bishop captures F captures
this sort of ruins Leon SP Pawn
structure but it also gives him more
control over the center and he does have
um additional control over the D5 Square
so if he wants he can push D5 at any
point uh not while D5 point is
undefended but once he takes care of
that it becomes a possibility so C3
Magnus kicks away the knight from this
Mighty B4 Square Knight back to C6 and
now Rook to E1 the pawn is now defended
and perhaps even Magnus is considered
ing D4 at some point we have Queen to D7
and that's exactly what Magnus does Pawn
to D4 striking in the center we have e
captures on D4 C captures on D4 and now
leavon advances the pawn all the way to
C4 and now you can already see that um
black maybe got a little bit more than
black should get out of the opening if
let's say B4 and C3 is played Black can
already claim a pass Pawn so okay Magnus
goes Bishop to G5 uh and pawn to H6 ask
Magnus what what is your Bishop even
doing here and Magnus uh decides not to
move the bishop back with something like
Bishop to E3 or Bishop to D2 he strikes
in the center with Pawn to D5 and of
course H captures and G5 is um somewhat
insufficient now due to D captures and
C6 Sol ofon plays e captures on D5 we
have Bishop captures uh uh on F6 First
bishop captures and now Queen captures
on D5 with check uh Rook to F7 and now
uh Queen all the way way back to D2
while you would enjoy D doubling up on
the D file your B2 Pawn is hanging so
you really have to do something about
that and Magnus moves the queen back
Queen to D2 so now we have this position
where leavon has this uh possibility of
B4 and C3 in the future and the bishop
nicely complimenting those pawns here
and the Magnus has um the weak D6 Pawn
to work with if if he's able to ever
attack it and here after Queen to D2 We
have Knight to
E5 uh putting pressure on the Knight
here and Magnus just trades we have
captures captures and now uh Knight to
E2 interestingly uh as I'm sure you guys
are wondering why not Knight to F5 it
looks like such a wonderful move just an
annoying Square to for black to face the
Knight and also it puts additional
pressure on D6 uh the problem is the
only thing defending the Knight on F5 is
this E4 pawn and you can now undermine
it with D5 and once you allow black to
execute D5 uh it's uh well equal to say
the least but black is the one who's in
control control now and best white can
hope for is to really commit with
something like F4 attack the bishop
Bishop will move in G4 and uh you know
hope for the best but let's say after d
captures everything gets traded off
captures captures uh it doesn't it
doesn't look like all that much uh for
white and it's still black has the same
threat B4 C3 creating a pass pawn and
the bishop will just be a monster here
so instead after Bishop capis on E5
Knight to E2 by Magnus uh and now we
have Rook F uh uh Rook B sorry Rook B
back to f8 uh gaining control of the f
file not allowing Pawn to F4 by Magnus
so here we have Rook to F1 uh
interestingly Pawn to F4 although it
looks like impossible is objectively the
best move here and I will just show why
because after Bishop captures and Knight
captures okay you you have given up a
pawn but there's Queen to D5 check and
now once black stops this by you know
any means now you'll play Rook eight to
D1 and you do have pressure on the D6
Pawn you also have pressure on B E5 if
the Queen ever moves so it's a it's a
fairly okay position for white but still
after Rook to F2 it just looks um it
just looks better for black also the be2
pawn is saying you will have pressure on
the king side so if anyone will be
better here it will be black so instead
Magnus played Rook to F1 but now leevon
plays the move that basically uh
characterizes this game and I'm not
going to tell you what move he played
because it's not the strongest move by
the engine I'm just going to tell you to
you know get in Leon's shoes you know
you've seen many Leon's games you know
how he plays you know how he thinks feel
free to pause the video and try to
figure out a leevon move while I give
you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
any of the awesome moves like Queen to
C6 and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh show congratulations
on spotting the leavon move and that is
Rook to F3 and and it's such an annoying
move to face not just because of course
you cannot capture I mean if you capture
then you you completely destroy your
king side and after we captures on F3
there's just not all that much you can
play here even a nice Rook to A3 okay
you threaten The Rook but still Queen
captures on H3 how are you getting out
of this there's just not much you can do
and even if Knight to F4 which sort of
is possible because if Rook captures
Rook captures Queen the problem is
Bishop captures Queen captures an F4 and
now of course black does capture the
White Queen right away black first
captures The Rook on F1 with check and
after King captures then only then Rook
captures on F4 and with two extra Pawns
of course this is easily winning for
black so instead after Rook to F3 Magnus
has to figure out a different plan he
plays Rook to A3 first which makes sense
but now Leon just plays Rook captures on
A3 and this ensures him a pass Pawn
without U well without working for his
meal all that much B captures on A3 was
played and now Queen to C6 before
pushing putting pressure on the E4 Pawn
so Knight to D4 attacking the queen uh
preparing to capture on B5 if Queen
captures on e4 also creating a past a
pawn H but not just Bishop captures on
D4 we have Queen captures and Rook to A8
leavon has everything nicely defended
here and he wants to go after the A3
Pawn so Magnus goes Rook to A1 but now
Pawn to C3 the queen is nicely set up
behind the pass Pawn uh Queen to B4 and
now we have Queen to C5 offering a queen
trade with Magnus of course cannot
accept the pawns are simply too strong
Queen to B3 check was played King to h8
and now Rook to A2 fighting for that C2
Square uh but there are just too many
weaknesses in magnus's Camp we have Rook
to A4 going after the E4 Pawn Rook to E2
defending and now just Rook captures on
A3 you cannot defend both A3 and E4 uh
Queen to D1 uh and now rug back to A8
and he was in this position un move 36
that Magnus Carlson resigned to the game
uh as there is nothing more to be done
here uh he will simply uh by he I mean
leevon will simply put the Rook on d8 uh
to guard the D pawn and then start
advancing the B Pawn One Way this could
conclude is let's say Magnus improves
the position of his King B4 his coming
and after something like F3 okay you
created a nice setup here uh Queen E5
check let's say G3 and now Queen to B5
uh just preparing to start advancing
those pawns and if Rook to C2 now just
Queen to C4 and now everything is in
position for the pawns to be marched
forward let's say Pawn H4 Pawn to B3
attacks The Rook Rook C1 Pawn to B2
attacks the rook and after Rook to C2 or
something doesn't really matter just
Rook A1 and that's it once the queen
moves the B1 Queen is coming and that's
pretty much it you could even hope for
some sort of a Perpetual here uh but uh
there's no way to accomplish it like if
you get the queen into the game Queen f8
check hoping for some Queen to F5 Queen
to f8 checking action uh there's the
simple Queen to G8 so there there's
really nothing to hope for here and uh
this is the first game they played
leevon won and I'm not going to tell you
what happened in the rest of the match
or in the rest of the candidates um
tournaments match as I'm planning to
cover it at some point but all in all an
excellent victory for Leon Aran
especially with this brilliant brilliant
Rook F3 move I mean look at this Rook to
F3 imagine playing something like this
against Magnus Carlson okay a fairly
younger Magnus Carlson but still I mean
Rook F3 against Magnus that's something
to you know to cherish dearly for the
rest of your life uh and yeah like I
said if you guys want to join us if you
want to be part of the fun I'm expecting
a lot of people to join first link in
the description below uh let's uh you
know enjoy and of course I will be
showcasing some of the games on my
channel I will be streaming most of the
games so maybe your game will also get
streamed against the very strong
Grandmaster where you crush him and then
of course everyone will uh get the
experience that with you uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
hope you guys will uh be able to join us
first link in the description below I
would like to thank Kenneth F Nikola
vich Maximo iseran Amelia Gray Scott and
Sven fer for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and see you soon